les défenseurs de la rainette faux
grillon triomphe aujourd'hui après une
saga judiciaire de sept ans c'est
vraiment un immense victoire aujourd'hui
pour la rainette faux grillon mais aussi
pour la biodiversité c'est un jugement
historique
l' affaire oppose la rainette faux
grillon une grenouille pas plus grande
qu'une pièce d'un dollar un adversaire
de taille
l'étalement urbain la cour suprême du
canada a rejeté la demande du groupe
maisons candiac d'invalider un décret
d'urgence émis par ottawa en 2016
sur ce terrain à la prairie le promoteur
comptait développer son projet le
gouvernement canadien en a empêchés pour
protéger la petite grenouille castanier
nous rappeler c'est que le droit de
propriété c'est pas un droit absolu et
que c'est dans notre devoir de nous
assurer que nos activités humaines ne
même pas à l'extinction des espèces la
rainette faux grillon a perdu 90% de son
aire de répartition géographique et les
menacés de disparition d'ici 2030
l'espèce est essentielle à plus d'un
titre c'est une espèce qui qui ont
d'importants nouveaux écologique donc
pour se débarrasser des maringouins
entre autres qui nous affligent et où
donc est là elle fait partie du cycle
écologique mais quelle valeur
intrinsèque et ça c'est un des éléments
super important que tu es relevés par
les différents jugements
c'est maintenant à québec d'agir croit
cet expert
c'est vraiment un appel aux différents
gouvernements provinciaux dont le québec
de moderniser les outils législatifs et
d'appliquer différemment à succès
existants pour s'assurer que la
biodiversité les espèces en péril en
particulier soient protégés le promoteur
groupe maisons candiac n'a pas accepté
notre demande d'entrevue et le maire de
la prairie n'était pas disponible ici à
ce mitraillage radio canada montréal